puede que no lo parezca pero esta mujer
estaba a punto de hacer historia esta
señora de 90 años es la primera persona
en el mundo en recibir por fuera de los
ensayos clínicos la vacuna que facer y
biotech desarrollaron contra el kobe 19
y listo
justo una semana antes de cumplir 91 y
ya está lista para celebrar también de
barbados o algún lugar la vacuna será
distribuida a lo largo del reino unido-
desde este martes dando prioridad a los
más vulnerables del país
estoy interesada en ponerme la si estoy
en la categoría extremadamente
vulnerable entonces espero que me la
pongan como parte de la distribución
pronto en algún punto y luego volver a
alguna clase de normalidad tanto como
sea posible
el primer ministro boris johnson expresó
un optimismo precavido durante solicita
a un puesto de vacunación en lo que fue
llamado como el día de es asombroso ver
salir la vacuna es asombroso ver esta
inyección en los brazos de la nación
entera pero no podemos permitirnos un
relajamiento ahora el hospital
universitario de croydon en el sur de
londres es uno de los 50 centros
clínicos que administrarán las primeras
dosis con el requerimiento de una
segunda vacuna 21 días después para
adquirir inmunidad este ha sido descrito
como el programa de inmunización más
grande de la historia distribuir las
primeras 800.000 dosis de la vacuna de
facer y biotech es todo un reto
logístico pues necesita ser almacenada a
menos 70 grados celsius en los ensayos
la inyección probó tener una eficacia de
cerca del 95% gobiernos y agencias
sanitarias de todo el mundo seguirán de
cerca del programa británico de
vacunación tomando nota de sus éxitos y
fracasos mientras esperan desplegar
programas similares en sus propios
países